hey guys it's Jan here I've been to see
Star Wars The Force awakens and I can
tell you right now that it kicks off the
new sequel trilogy in super fine form
it's a really emotional movie in all
sorts of ways in fact there were several
very different occasions when I felt
myself welling up even a new hope gave
us three young stars who worked so
beautifully together and the force
awakens repeats the magic with the
brilliant casting of Daisy Ridley John
boyega and Oscar Isaac after the
disappointment of Natalie Portman's
character Padme in the prequels it's
great to see a fantastic and interesting
female character who actually gets to do
stuff rather than sit around and were
5,000 different hairstyles Ridley's come
from being on almost no one's radar
having appeared in a few British TV
shows to being the center of a whole
galaxy and let me tell you she is on
foreign formers ray managing to play
each scene to its full potential whether
that's big action set-pieces heroes
exchanges or more subdued or tender
moments and the on-screen chemistry is
superb between her and John boyega who
plays stormtrooper Finn boyega burst
onto the big screen in the alien
invasion action comedy attack the block
and followed that up with performances
in a number of indie films including a
terrific turn in the Sundance Award
winner Imperial dreams and he really
looks like he's having an absolute blast
on the force awakens he's got a real
gift for comedy and he has some fabulous
scenes with Harrison Ford but he's also
just as good when it's drama action or a
touch of vulnerability that's called for
Oscar Isaacs been turning in some
absolutely stonking performances over
the past few years from the coen
brothers movie inside Llewyn Davis to
the superlatives IFI flick ex machina
and he's definitely on point as x-wing
Squadron Leader Poe Dameron who gets a
nice mix of action and humorous dialogue
Adam driver who's best known for the HBO
show girls is brilliant as kylo Ren and
get some suitably dramatic moments and
it was pretty cool seeing him wield his
spiti crossguard lightsaber I really
felt spoiled for amazing actors in
episode 7 another of them being Donal
Gleeson who you may have seen over the
past 12
months in movies like ex machina
Brooklyn and unbroken as general Hux
Gleason puts in a fantastically
fanatical performance Gwendoline
Christie so incredible as the badass
Brienne in Game of Thrones there was a
little disappointed that she didn't
feature a bit more as Captain phasma in
the force awakens though she did a good
job when she is on screen the king of
performance capture Andy Serkis plays
the intriguing and rather mysterious
Supreme Leader Snoke and also appearing
by a performance capture Lupita Nyong'o
puts in a charming turn as the ancient
alien pirate Maz Kanata by the way if
you're a fan of the awesome Indonesia
martial arts movie the raid look out for
its stars and fight choreographer Zico
you a and the iron rien who get a cool
little scene in the movie and of course
it's so good to see Harrison Ford Carrie
Fisher and Mark Hamill backers Han Leia
and Luke there are some really heartfelt
moments between han and Leia and when we
first see Ford and Fisher on screen it
feels like they return to the world of
Star Wars after all these years gives
added meaning and poignancy to the words
that Leia and Han say to each other and
of course Peter Mayhew and cheerio back
to and what's not to love about that
adorable worky there's some lovely
interaction between chewy and Han all of
which is very reminiscent of some of my
favorite moments in the original trilogy
as for the droids I absolutely loved
bb-8 he makes a really wonderful
addition to the franchise and sound
designer a mix of Ben Burtt he's worked
on all the Star Wars movies is on fine
form yet again ensuring that bb-8 is
full of personality and makes a lasting
impression it feels like he's the r2d2
of this new trilogy as for r2d2 himself
there's not as much of him as I'd hoped
but when we do see him it feels like
it's worth waiting for and I can't
forget c-3po who's as funny as ever and
I just love the way he first appears in
the movie classic also returning to the
galaxy far far away is oscar-winning
composer John Williams whose music
really made the original trilogy and
it's a delight to hear him mix and find
new music with his much-loved original
themes and JJ Abrams and composer Lin
Manuel Miranda who created the Broadway
musical Hamilton did really excellent
work with the music on the new Cantina
star seen talking of JJ Abrams here in
lawrence kasdan who wrote The Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi have
written a script that's a wonderful mix
of action adventure humor heart and
nostalgia there's plenty of Easter eggs
and callbacks to the previous films and
i'll be making a video about that and
I'll add the annotation here when it's
live I felt like the movies 135 minute
run time just flew by props to Abraham's
Kasdan and the film's editors Mary Ann
Brandon and Mary Jo Marquis for keeping
things rattling along the only place i
would have liked it to have taken a
little bit more time was in the cantina
scene as there were so many cool
creatures and some of them just whizzed
by too quickly not giving me enough time
to properly appreciate the incredible
work of Neil Scanlon and his creature
effects team a shout-out also goes to
cinematographer dan Mendell and costume
designer Michael Kaplan who both worked
with Abrams on multiple movies and to
make up department head amanda night and
her team who's no stranger to
blockbusters having worked on all the
Harry Potter movies all of them did
Stella work on the force awakens there's
a ton of thrilling and spectacular
action in the movie thanks to the hard
work of huge teams led by stunt
coordinator Rob inch special effects
supervisor Chris cobalt whose work we
last saw inspector and visual effects
supervisors Michael Mulholland Roger yet
and Nick Shay again the effort that's
gone into all the film's design and sets
is just phenomenal production designers
Rick Carter and Darren guilford and set
decorator loose on Dallas should be
rightfully very happy with the world's
they've created so to sum up the feel
and tone of the force awakens fits
perfectly with episodes 4 to 6 making it
a wonderfully welcome return to the
world of Star Wars it's full of laughter
emotion intrigue action and stunning
visuals basically it's a fantastic
combination of the old and the new with
a superb cast and top-notch work from
the whole crew star wars the force
awakens gets 5 out of 5 flicks now what
are you looking forward to most about
the force awakens or if you've seen it
already what did you think I
nope to know your experiences did you
see it at midnight did you cosplay did
it live up to your expectations and who
are your favorite new characters in the
movie let me know in the comments below
I'm going to be making a video about the
top WTF moments in the movie as well as
an easter egg video and I'll add
annotations for those here as soon as
their live and as always do please like
leave your comments and share this video
and hit that subscribe button for more
videos like this thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers
you